over the past few months we've been
telling you the stories of people who
say they were falsely arrested even put
in jail after hertz car rental filed
police reports claiming wrongly that
their rental cars had been stolen we
estimate based on the company's figures
released in court that hertz files an
average of 3 500 stolen car reports per
year
now only on cbs mornings we have the
story of one of those hertz customers
who is sitting in jail right now as we
speak
our consumer investigative correspondent
anna werner spoke with him
that's charles doucette speaking with us
from florida's brevard county jail last
week the pharmacy and health care
consultant from new hampshire says he
was on a caribbean cruise with his
girlfriend back in port in florida early
friday morning they were sleeping when a
knock came at the door
he was being arrested why
last year ducette says he had rented a
car from hertz for his business properly
extending the rental several times but
in march police in arizona stopped him
and told him hertz had filed a police
report saying his rental car had been
stolen they towed the car but ducette
says afterwards hertz charged his credit
card the full amount for the rental yet
in august prosecutors acting on hertz's
police report took his case to a grand
jury and indicted him facing a required
court appearance in arizona he says he
contacted a local attorney there and
sent notarized documents so he wouldn't
have to appear in person it's not clear
what occurred in the local court but the
next thing that happened was he was
arrested
and here i am sitting in jail especially
since he says he's been an elite
president circle member who in 2020 and
2021 spent over 15 thousand dollars with
hertz
this is his girlfriend of 18 years who
didn't want to be identified because of
her job
i just want him home i just want answers
so we can pick up the pieces and move on
230 people have filed claims in
bankruptcy courts saying hertz filed a
false police report against them hurt
says situations where vehicles are
reported to the authorities are very
rare and happen only after exhaustive
attempts to reach the customer attorney
francis alexander malafi represents
doucet and other claimants hertz refuses
to correct a police report when they
learn payments made when they learned
the car's been returned or when they
learn that there's inaccuracies
to affect somebody's
we asked hertz about doucet's case the
company did not respond to those
questions attorney malafi sent this
letter to the company over the weekend
asking hertz to help get duset out of
jail he says unless something changes
doucet will be in jail for a minimum of
10 days because he's awaiting
extradition to arizona michelle
unbelievable anna just just
it is it is
it's it's extremely well documented at
this point and it's it's going to be
interesting to see what what hurts says
as it continues to have to deal with
these cases in court
and 230 other people like him all right
anna